hi I'm Erik Bosse and Shazam is a
wish-fulfilling escape from the doom and
gloom of superhero cinema these days a
breath of fresh air that ain't 50% dust
of dead Avengers this latest DC
installment is filled with interesting
Easter eggs and details that you might
have missed
let's rewatch it and break it down see
by scene for all these limited edition
goodies were learning if we haven't seen
it yet and let's get started the opening
scene introduces us to the film's
villain that is sivanna a young boy
bullied by his father and brother in the
comics dr. sivana has appeared as a mad
scientist and in the more recent new 52
relaunch scientist on an archaeological
expedition to save his family until
being scarred with magic released from
the tomb of Black Adam Warren him in a
bit but this film is further humanized
in Savano with this backstory making him
a parallel figure to the hero Billy
Batson kind of a worst case scenario if
things played out differently for Billy
this flashback to 1974 opens with Bing
Crosby's rendition of do you hear what I
hear setting this story at Christmastime
and reflecting the frustration of
Savannah's character in this core memory
desperately begging the sceptics around
him to hear what he heard and see what
he saw Savannah's fathers played by John
Glover a longtime DC actor he voiced the
Riddler and Batman the Animated Series
he played dr. Jason wood drew the
scientist behind poison ivy and Bane in
the beloved Batman and Robin and he
played Lex Luthor's father Lionel Luthor
in Smallville and he has looked exactly
the same for three decades young
Savannah's magic 8-ball shows seven
symbols leaving the father's car to
blast to the rock of eternity a sort of
hub of all magic in the DC world its
keeper is the wizard whose name is
actually Shazam and he's played by China
and Han su uncie it's really a triple
dipping in the superhero films these
days he played supporting roles in
Aquaman and Captain Marvel and speaking
of the name Captain Marvel this is a
reminder that Shazam's original name was
Captain Marvel he existed long before
Marvel Comics Captain Marvel did his
name was actually one of the first DC
superheroes to show up on the map but
over time DC just decided to do the
heroic thing and stick with the name
Shazam to avoid the confusion not all
heroes wear capes except this one does
as in the comics the wizard is the
surviving member of the Council of
eternity seeking a champion to grant the
power of the wisdom of Solomon the
strength of Hercules a stamina of Atlas
power of Zeus the courage of Achilles in
this
speed of mercury take the first letter
of all those gods and you got Shapton
marvel chin the cave DC of course Shazam
this rock of eternity contains these
seven deadly sins gluttony greed sloth
lust pride envy and wrath sin the box
these comics do love their lists in the
recent comics these entities take sort
of humanoid form with more personalities
here they're more demonic and monstrous
as savanah enters this cave there's a
little cameo by this caterpillar looking
thing in a jar this is actually the DC
villain mr. mind a super intelligent
telepathic worm who appears in the
movies post-credits scene but I made a
whole other video explaining that
post-credits scene so go watch it
sivanna gets tempted by the voices of
the sins who take the eye of sin and
notice this shot is that eye gleams off
his glasses lens this blue light
reflects over the exact spot where their
orb will later scar his eye so sivanna
blows it he returns to the car freaking
out and causing a rat carrying the kind
of guilt that'll turn any cat into a
super villain leading to the
introduction of Billy Batson played by
Asher Angel his hometown of Philadelphia
is one of many details inspired by the
new 52 relaunch of Shazam by Geoff Johns
including the Christmas time set in
Philly as a foster kid moving from home
to home his five foster siblings who all
get Shazam powers as well and specific
plot points like the bully fight
wrecking the bully's car and events
setting them all in Christmas village we
first see Billy tricking cops by faking
a pawn shop burglary now in this pawn
shop there's an easter egg of the doll
from Annabelle sitting on the shelf this
movie's director's david s Sandberg he's
an emerging horror filmmaker who
previously directed Annabelle creation
the director James 1 is kind of taken
him under his wing and if you remember
one actually snuck his own Annabelle
cameo into Aquaman as Billy uses the
police records to try to track down his
stupid mom we flash back to the moment
this garbage person abandoned the child
at the carnival booth young Billy wants
a stuffed tiger which is one of the many
Tiger nods this movie to mr. talkie
Thani
an anthropomorphic tiger and friend is
Shazam in the comics as a teenager
you'll notice Billy's backpack has a
tiger head on back now instead of this
booth Billy gets this compass ball
prized and it's interesting how this
prop parallels the ball toy of the
villain sivanna the magic 8-ball
the magic 8-ball is fake magic it's mere
toy and this artificiality reflects
sivanna's on
worthiness of magical powers whereas a
compass ball if you think about it is
actually linked to real natural forces
magnetism of the poles and this reflects
Billy's natural fit its champion and
that said magic 8-balls are way cooler
compass balls are like their poor kids
Billy gets arrested and meets with this
social worker Emma Glover played by Andy
osho osho actually played this same
character in Sandburg first feature
lights out a future version of his
amazing short film on Blair's desk are a
bunch of yellow smiley faces Sandburg
said that behind the nametag is a
blood-stained one a nod to the iconic
image from The Watchmen Billy meets his
new foster parents Rosa and Victor
Vasquez played by Martin melons and
Cooper Andrews aka Jerry from the
walking dead
they take him home where he meets his
foster siblings Eugene Choi played by
Ian Chen Darla Dudley played by faith
Herman Mary Brown fields plays by grace
Bolton petrol pay me up play by hope in
Arman and Freddie Freeman ek Eddie from
its and in my opinion at the MVP of this
film in the original Captain Marvel
Comics Freddie and Mary were kind of
sidekick characters Captain Marvel jr.
and Mary Marvel but in the more recent
new 52 series all five siblings make up
the Marvel family they all get powers
and these kids look remarkably similar
to these actors with the exception of
Freddy not being blond
notice how the costume designers tend to
dress all these kids in the exact colors
that they later wear as their Shazam
forms you know kind of like the Power
Rangers look Jason just liked red okay
also a little detail here when Victor
lifts the gaming headphones off Eugene's
ear you can hear the sound mixers
dropped in a little grill home screen
Freddy's room is wall-to-wall DCU
references there's a wooden Superman toy
on the shelf a Batman V Superman
Batarang replica which comes back a book
titled the bird in the plane the impact
of superheroes on society and its future
and authentic smoosh Superman bullet
newspapers with headlines about Assad's
invasion and Man of Steel the
congressional hearing and Batman V
Superman and ones about Lex Corp and
Superman Freddy where is an Aquaman
t-shirt the first of many Justice League
shirts aware throughout the film and the
wall there's a framed newspaper with the
headline Superman is back which we saw
in the events of Justice League and
their sub headlines amazon woman in the
batman help combat lex luthor plans
suggesting a team-up between Batman and
Wonder Woman also the aftermath Gotham
citizens pick up the pieces and on the
lower left
alien attack on the war
with the text underneath saying the top
suspect as worldwide search begins for
those responsible specialists say early
signs point to Lex Luthor and his
associates and all of these are hinting
to the events following the near
apocalypse of the Justice League film
you know what that's a bit easy to
forget but you know it plagued the earth
with swarms of parademons as Steppenwolf
sought mother boxes to open up boom
tubes and allow Darkseid to come to
earth
remember the host ace it's interesting
that this newspaper specifies Lex Luthor
and his associates it's possible hint to
Justice League's post-credits scene evil
team-up with Lex Luthor and Deathstroke
which many of us assumed would be the
origin of the Legion of Doom in the DC
EU unfortunately it looks like those
plans have been stalled at the moment in
general this whole Shazam movie is fully
integrated in the world of the DC EU so
these boys see everything through a lens
of a reference base of DC same things
like Cape Crusader stuff more powerful
than a locomotive
most of them are obvious so I'm not
gonna point them out but it's also
interesting that apparently Game of
Thrones exists in this universe - Freddy
jokes with Billy about his disability
saying Victor pushed me it gets real
Game of Thrones around here he's
referencing the first episode when Jaime
Lannister pushed bran out the window and
paralyzed him moving on to adults Ivana
played by Mark Strong interviewing
others who like him encountered the
wizard but were rejected as champions
seeing the crazy experiences of
alternate candidates is another new 52
inspiration the comics show a random guy
freaking out as his elevator blast of
the rock of eternity there's actually a
very interesting detail here but first
this video was sponsored by expressvpn a
VPN allows you to browse the internet
with privacy without things like dad
companies hackers spyware any of those
annoying things tracking your data and
secretly filtering your whole internet
experience Express me if Ian asks your
IP address to make sure you aren't being
monitored so you can have that peace of
mind you can live life knowing no one is
beeping on you personally I use Express
VPN because when I search for phrases
like I of sin and lust in the same hour
I don't want search engines and AD
companies make it any weird assumptions
about what I want it's just for work
guys
Express maybe in is the fastest VPN on
the market and the number one VPN
service rated by TechRadar and if you're
in a different country you might not be
able to access everything on Netflix or
YouTube or other streaming services but
thanks to express VPN you can avoid
those
restrictions and just watch everything
that you want to normally the way the
Internet should be wherever you are
expressvpn lets you securely stream or
download content from anywhere anytime
and it's less than seven dollars a month
with a 30-day money-back guarantee so
take back your internet privacy today
and find out how you can get three
months for free by clicking on the link
in the description box expressvpn comm
slash new rock stars
that's exp ress VPN comm slash new rock
stars for three months free with one
year package visit Express bbm comm
slash new rockstars to learn more take
back your Internet privacy today
okay Savano works with dr. Crosby who
researches mass delusions and this
character is actually a cameo by l'hotel
austin Sandberg's real-life wife she
starred in Sandberg's amazing horror
short films and had cameos in the lights
out feature and Annabel creation
Crosby's disintegration here is freaking
me she releases this haunting wail is
her jaw collapses an ash it's a reminder
of how gifted Sandburg is at creating
vivid horror especially when it comes to
horrible things happening to his wife
sivanna returns to the rock of eternity
this time embracing the eye of sin
giving in to the seven deadly sins which
break out of there encasing statues
which crumble around them much like the
way it does with the demons cracking out
of their statues and movie ghostbusters
Billy Freddy and the others attend
Fawcett Central School which is a
reference to Shazam / captain Marvel's
previous hometown in the DC Comics
Fawcett City which was named after
Fawcett comics the company that
originally created the character before
being bought out by DC Freddy now wears
an orange Batman shirts with the logo
from the batfleck era and despite his
sweet swag the evilest bullies in the
world attempt vehicular manslaughter on
him and somehow don't go to jail in this
movie instead they just get like hit a
few times my Billy and their car gets
wrecked and they get suitcase wedgies no
not enough you run over someone with
your car that's a felony you target a
kid with disabilities it's a hate crime
prison Billy flees these [ __ ] in a
subway car shoots off to the rock of
eternity
notice that the Jarrah previously
containing mr. mind is now shattered and
empty setting up his return of the
post-credits scene in this cave you can
also see a mirror this is a nod to
Francesca in the comics presidents who
appears to Billy in any reflective
surface
the wizard explains to Billy the whole
history of the Council of eternity long
ago chose a previous
champion who betrayed them and released
the seven deadly sins into the world
he doesn't specify but this past
champion was actually black Adam the
main antagonist - Shazam who will be
played in a future DC film by Dwayne the
rock Johnson left with no option to be
picky about champions anymore the wizard
grants Billy his powers
she's handsome he turns them into the
adult Shazam played by Zachary Levi now
if you look closely the clasps of his
cape show Tiger heads another talky Tony
nod Shazam finds Freddie and freaks him
out this movie was pitched as Tom Hanks
his big meets Superman and this plot
point is straight out of big the scene
when adult Josh scares his buddy Billy
Josh wins them over by performing their
inside joke ice cream song Billy wins
over Freddie by bringing up the nerdy
flight versus a visibility debate and
showing him his stolen Superman bullet
Levi's portrayal of a kid trapped in an
adult body it's really well nuanced they
did a really good job working in the
expressions from the comics phrases like
holy moley
gee whiz Shazam uses his adult myths to
try to buy beer notice how the brand he
buys is called
bearish David Sandberg is Swedish and
bearish again sorry about the
pronunciation its Swedish slang for beer
kind of like the way we say brewski or
things that my dad hides around the
house this leads to Shazam foiling a
robbery in small detail hear that I
liked the little dimples of the bullets
make is they ricochet off his face this
leads to one of my favorite scenes in
the movie sivanna confronting the board
of directors of his father and brothers
company David Sandberg background is a
horror film maker gave this scene such a
dark tone notice of the board members
look genuinely horrified when sivanna
throws his brother out the window
samberg's work here reminds me a lot of
Sam Raimi's direction of the first
spider-man movie Raimi was also better
known for his practical horror in the
Evil Dead movies but like Sandberg he
ended up making a very fun
wish-fulfillment story with the right
amount of cheese and the right amount of
surprising jump scares remember the
scene where Green Goblin horrific Lee
murders the Oscorp board of directors
one of them was in a wheelchair and it
definitely seems like an inspiration for
this Shazam scene these board members
get torn to pieces by the demonic seven
deadly sins and the film's creative team
put a lot of work into designing each
element their skin texture the hair the
bumps the amount of saliva in their
mouths to make them comparable evils
that emerge from the body but just
enough variation to tell them part of
clothes gluttony is a big flab
o-obviously prize stands proudly with
large wings greed has multiple arms more
things to claw at riches with lust has a
salacious venom like tongue I too
thought lust would be hotter wrath is a
hulking rage monster now envy is the
runt of the litter smaller thinner
hanging back often hiding inside
Savannah as his primary vice because
Envy by his nature lacks what the others
possessed it sloth is a bit harder to
make out he's another big guy but his
arms lazily dangle with tentacle fingers
that mop the floor you could see him a
bit more clearly later on meanwhile
Shazam and Freddie test out powers that
the Queen's don't stop me now the ski
trip where they test flight has ariane
written and graffiti on the side Ariane
is actually a character from the DC
Comics an Atlantian sorcerer who's been
both a hero in the villain in different
series Freddy uploads these videos to
YouTube where he could see all his
alternate names for this superhero
thundercrack captain thunder captain
sparkle fingers sir zaps a lot mr.
Philadelphia there's also zapped in
America and not to our boy cap and Power
boy perhaps a nod to Power Man aka Luke
Cage from the Marvel world it seems like
the name that sticks for now is red
cyclone which is a nod to a more obscure
DC figure Red Tornado really all of
these jokes are making light of the
confusion over Shazam / captain Marvel's
name over the years and the fact that
Shazam tends to come up as a silly
superhero reference and passion on her
films Shazam and Freddie visit a real
estate office hoping to buy a lair
they mentioned wanting it hidden behind
a waterfall a reference to the Batcave
and in the scene Freddie now whereas
another Aquaman shirt Atlantis lifeguard
I want that later when Billy realizes he
can just ditch school look at the school
bus behind him denne bus lines
that's a nod to veteran comic book
writer Denny O'Neil
and from this point on into the third
act Freddie now wears a Superman shirt
perhaps a signal that this will be the
day he Superman's up with his own Shazam
powers Shazam hangs out at the top of
the steps of the art museum showing off
- I have a tiger lightning with my hands
there's another Tiger reference for you
plus earlier Shazam mentions that this
is a spot that rocky ran to the top of
and his famous montage and I the tiger
was the theme song Rocky 3 recorded by
survivor specifically for that movie he
accidentally snapped
causing it to crash through the barrier
at the top of an overpass and shazam
catching it here evokes the classic
moment Christopher Reeves Superman
caught the bus falling off the Golden
Gate Bridge in the Richard Donner
Superman sivanna finds him after this
leading to Shazam discovering his flight
power and a bike crashing through
Philadelphia skyscrapers similar to the
memorable Superman Zod battle and Man of
Steel they use the buildings of
Metropolis like sloppy joes in a food
fight this fight spills over into a mall
toy store where shelves are lined with
DC merch costumes and toys for various
Justice League members it is we were
promised there's a very fun homage to
big Shazam at sivanna briefly run into a
giant floor keyboard just like Tom Hanks
and Robin OSHA probably too much task
for Savannah and Shazam's footwork to
lead to heart and soul or chopsticks and
hopefully deleted scenes when Billy
disappears in the crowd at the mall
notice the screen in the background
showing this animation this cartoon is
David Sandberg first short film it's all
in Swedish but it seems to Lakeville
back at home Billy's foster family sees
the news broadcasts reported by galaxy
broadcasting systems galaxies the name
of the TV station in the comics and when
Billy returns Eugene shares with them
the information about his biological
parents
his mother's current address and he says
that his father was named CC Batson CC
is a nod to CC Beck conic artist and
co-creator of the Captain Marvel
character back in 1939 Billy's mother
disappoints him again because she's a
garbage person and her garbage boyfriend
is actually a vocal cameo by David
Sandberg but this disappointment is an
important step for Billy's maturation
symbolized by him handing off his
compass ball to her just like Savannah
let go of his magic 8-ball the moment he
severed ties with his family holding him
back allowing him to redefine himself as
a supervillain Billy now does the same
redefining himself as a superhero and
this leads to the definitive
supercharged moment in every superhero
movie where Billy trusts way too much in
the power of Zeus to hit him mid suicide
jump but this is a true leap of faith
Bruce Wayne jumping to freedom in the
Dark Knight Rises
actually the framing of Billy as he
steps toward the edge of the rooftop
mirrors the framing that we've seen in
parallel moments for every other past DC
EU hero shows an immense up back in the
rock of eternity with sivanna and the
seven deadly sins and the Batarang makes
a great comeback between the Batarang
and the Smosh Superman bullet I just
love how Freddy's collectibles
coming back into the story it's key plot
devices like the image of these smooshed
bullets is the moment that Shazam
realizes his bullet immunity in the
convenience store and a Batarang reveals
Savannah's weakness that the guy can
bleed a symbol of Superman to show
strength a symbol of Batman to show
vulnerability
actually Sam escapes with foster
siblings they passed a series of
Monsters Inc style doors
one contains a bunch of crocodiles
playing cards like I guess the dog
painting but this is actually a
reference to the crocodile men from the
DC comics another door shows a deep fog
with some nasty tentacle monster this
could be another horror homage to
Stephen King's the mist a really
underrated film by Frank Darabont the
action returns to the Christmas village
at the carnival
as Billy / Sam comes full circle with
his origin he even crashes back into the
same balloon dart booth and he gives the
stuffed tiger that he wanted to this
little girl to keep her calm this whole
third act works really well largely
because so much of it is callbacks to
past moments Billy catches the punch by
Savannah mirror and Savannah catching
his punch earlier and he powers up his
foster siblings by saying all hands on
deck Ria's he and his foster fathers
hands in call for grace before meals
something he never took part in now
finally bringing Billy into the family
and yeah all the kids shouting Billy
instead of Shazam awesome so all that
gets powerup to adult versions of
themselves Shazam Darla is Megan good
Shazam Eugene is Ross Butler Shazam Mary
is michelle borth and pedrad Freddy's
Castine is especially significant Pedro
is played by DJ cotrona who is
originally announced as Superman in
George Miller's 2007 Justice League
mortal film that never happened
unfortunately and Freddy is Adam Brody
the OC who was cast as the flash in that
movie and looks freakishly like an older
Jack Dylan grazier perfect casting as
the family takes on the seven deadly
sins Shazam and savannas fight moves
over to downtown Philly the hilarious
gag of Savannah giving his evil speech
too far away for Sam to hear it a boy
plays with Superman a Batman action
figures clashing them into each other
perhaps recreating their battle and
Batman V Superman when Eugene blasts one
of the sins he shouts Bugan a nod to
street fighter and later after Shazam
holds Savannah by the neck it pulls out
the I've sinned Eugene says fatality a
nod to mortal combat which we actually
saw them playing earlier on but the way
is Shazam ultimately defeats ivana is
interesting cuz throughout the then we
see him use most of his powers the
strength of Hercules this stamina
Atlas the power of Zeus the courage of
Achilles the speed of mercury but not
often the wisdom of Solomon it's kind of
stupid actually like all kids are to be
fair but in this moment Shazam / Billy
cleverly invokes wisdom by taunting the
envy out of Savannah so that Savannah is
vulnerable and notice how Envy pops out
of Savannah's face much like the random
bilbo baggins jump-scare and fellowship
of the ring mmm and I suppose in that
moment you could argue that the ring was
inspiring Envy in Bilbo and the mix with
grief pretty much all this is the final
scene returns to the school where the
foster kids joined together at one table
in Shazam helps Freddy who now wears a
Wonder Woman shirt here deliver on his
promise for him to show up at lunch
along with a celebrity cameo by the Man
of Steel carrying a lunch tray they had
to show Superman from the neck down here
due to contract disputes with Henry
Cavill so they had Zack Levi stunt guy
step in as a body double now here's what
I'm curious about from you guys over the
years the wizard could afford to be
picky about his champion he turned down
everyone but he ended up settling for
Billy Batson after being forced to since
Savannah freed the seven deadly sins
Billy it wasn't exactly the noblest Boy
Scout out there so do you think Billy
would have been seduced by the I of sin
the way Savannah was do you think young
Savannah could have been a worthy
champion if the wizard was as desperate
as he was with Billy comment down below
with your thoughts follow me on
Instagram and Twitter Eddie a vas and
subscribe to new Rockstar so deep dives
and everything you love thanks for
watching bye
[Music]